des questions à monsieur blanc merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je suis ravie en vous écoutant depuis 1h
d'entendre effectivement qu'on a ce
potentiel d'une dynamique maritime
extraordinaire dans notre pays je crois
que c'est une chance ma question est est
plus pragmatique et évidemment pétrole
de l'interministériel mais j'aimerais
bien voir alors pas ce soir j'imagine
mais avoir une présentation de l'état
sanitaire en lien avec les ars bien sûr
mais des sanitaires des côtes et mais
finalement aussi de l'ensemble du
domaine maritime nationale évidemment
métropolitain et ultramarin vous ai
parlé plastique je trouve que c'est
dommage d'attendre 2025
mais il ya aussi on le sait très bien
toujours des rejets d'eaux usées
chimiques
donc j'aimerais bien avoir une
présentation ou un état des lieux
des côtes maritimes françaises au niveau
sanitaire
merci madame la ministre